tengo aquí unas impresiones de pantalla
de algunos ejercicios de lacan academy
sobre cómo interpretar la tasa de cambio
en funciones exponenciales en términos
del cambio y bueno tal vez debería de
cambiarles el título porque es un título
muy muy largo pero lo importante es este
problema así que vamos a trabajarlo dice
nora subió a su sitio web un vídeo
gracioso que rápidamente obtiene visitas
a lo largo del tiempo la relación entre
el tiempo transcurrido t en días desde
que no la subió el vídeo y el número
total de vistas de dtm observa esta
función es una función que depende del
tiempo que en este caso está dado en
días en días desde que no ahora subió el
vídeo se modela con la siguiente función
de dtm es igual a 100 que multiplica a
1.53 elevado a la atm y aquí está el
tiempo en días completas la siguiente
oración sobre la tasa de cambio diaria
del número de vistas del vídeo
cada día el número de vistas crece o
decrece y bueno para que todo te quede
mucho más claro qué te parece si por
aquí hacemos una pequeña tabla para que
todo sea más ordenado así que por aquí
voy a hacer mi tabla por aquí voy a
hacer mi tabla esta va a ser mi otra
parte de mi tabla y del lado izquierdo
voy a poner al tiempo mientras que del
lado derecho voy a poner a petete muy
bien y qué va a pasar con el tiempo vale
cero bueno cuando el tiempo vale cero
observa aquí va a ir un cero y entonces
me va a quedar 100 que multiplica a 1.53
elevado a la potencia 0 pero 1.53
elevado a la potencia cero sabemos que
es 1 por lo tanto solamente me quedan
100 por 1 lo cual es 100
déjame ponerlo 100 muy bien ahora qué
pasa cuando el tiempo vale 1 bueno
cuando el tiempo vale 1 aquí me va a
quedar un 1 y entonces me va a quedar
100 x 1.50 y 3 elevado en la potencia 1
es lo mismo que 100 7 que multiplica a
1.53 de lujo ahora qué pasa cuando el
tiempo vale 2 bueno si el tiempo vale 2
aquí me va a quedar un 1.53 le pagó al
cuadrado y entonces esto se va a ver
como 100 100 que multiplica a 1.53 esto
elevado al cuadrado o lo que es lo mismo
esto a su vez x 1.50 y 3 así que observa
y bueno esto viene de la definición de
una función exponencial cada día que
pasa tenemos 1.53 veces la cantidad
anterior 1.53 veces la cantidad anterior
así que cada día que pasa tenemos 1.53
veces más que el número de vistas del
día anterior y bueno como 1.53 es un
número más grande que uno entonces
podemos decir que el número de vistas va
a
crecer entonces déjame ponerlo aquí
crece y bueno no estoy en el sitio de la
canacar min pero si tú estuvieras ahí
tendría que apretar este botón y
seleccionar la opción crece y bueno cada
día el número de vistas crece en un
factor de y bueno ya sabemos cuál es
nuestro factor nuestros factores 1.53
1.53 muy bien vamos a hacer otro de
estos problemas así que para eso déjame
bajar un poco más esta pantalla y vamos
a trabajar con el siguiente problema y
éste dice mira es una ecologista que
estudia los cambios en una población de
osos en siberia a lo largo del tiempo la
relación entre el tiempo transcurrido t
en años desde que viva empezó a estudiar
la población y el número de osos en el
dtm se modela con la siguiente función
ahora nuestro tiempo están años en el dt
es igual y bueno tenemos esta función
que aquí tenemos nuestras cosas
completa la siguiente oración sobre la
tasa de cambio anual de la población de
osos cada año la población de osos y
bueno qué te parece si hacemos también
una tabla para ver cómo está afectando
en nuestro factor de dos tercios así que
déjame hacer por aquí también una tabla
voy a cambiar de color voy a hacer fue
que una tabla una tabla y bueno por aquí
tengo al tiempo al tiempo y esta vez
tengo la función n dt n de este muy bien
cuando el tiempo es 0 bueno tengo 2.187
osos es decir cuando han pasado 0 años
en el primer día o en el primer año más
bien en el que estudia los osos y
después cuando el tiempo vale 1 entonces
tengo dos tercios elevado la primera
potencia lo cual me queda dos mil 187
que multiplica a 2
tercios muy bien y cuando el tiempo vale
dos bueno tengo dos mil 187 que
multiplicamos a dos tercios elevado al
cuadrado dos tercios por dos tercios de
lujo entonces cada año tengo dos tercios
la cantidad de osos que tenía en el año
anterior dos tercios la cantidad de osos
que tenía en el año anterior por lo
tanto cada año la población de osos
decrece en esta ocasión de crece de
crecer en un factor de y bueno ya
sabemos que es dos tercios muy bien
vamos a hacer un problema más y para eso
voy a bajar la pantalla y vamos a
trabajar con este problema que tengo
aquí y este dice aquí va empezó a
estudiar la manera en la que el número
de ramas de su árbol crece a lo largo
del tiempo la relación entre el tiempo
transcurrido t en años desde que aquí va
empezó a estudiar él
y el número de ramas en el dt se modela
con la siguiente función aquí está
completa la siguiente oración sobre el
cambio porcentual anual del número de
ramas cada año espacio en blanco por
ciento de ramas se suma o se resta del
número total de ramas muy bien si
tenemos aquí esta función y observas que
cada año vamos a multiplicar por 1 punto
75 es decir cada año vamos a tener 1
punto 75 veces el número de ramas que
teníamos el año anterior entonces puedes
ver que nuestro factor va a ser 1.75
pero esta vez nos preguntan el
porcentaje de ramas entonces si tenemos
1.75 veces el número de ramas que
teníamos el año anterior y eso quiere
decir que tenemos un 75% 75% de ramas
nuevas es decir tú creces en un 75% de
ramas por lo tanto cada año
75% de ramas se suma se suman del número
total de ramas y bueno para hacer esto
muy claro voy a hacer de nuevo una tabla
para que veas qué es lo que está pasando
así que vamos a hacer por aquí una
pequeña tabla y de nuevo veas cómo está
cambiando nuestra función de lujo cuando
el tiempo vale cero bueno pues tenemos
42 ramas 42 ramas y cuando el tiempo
vale 1 cuando ha pasado un año bueno
pues tenemos 42 ramas 42 ramas que
multiplican a 1.75 muy bien y cuando
tenemos dos ramas tenemos 42 que
multiplica a 1.75 que a su vez
multiplica a 1.75 muy bien y así puedes
ver que cada año multiplicamos por un
factor de 1.75 cada año multiplicamos
por 1
1 275 ahora bien observa si tú estás
multiplicando por un factor de 1.75 si
tú crees es en un factor de 1.75 esto es
lo mismo que está sumando un 75% una vez
más aquí lo que hicimos fue sumar un 75%
si tú por ejemplo quisiera sumar un 10%
bueno tendrías que multiplicar por un
factor de 1.10 si tú quisieras por un
factor de un hombre bueno pues realmente
tendrías una misma cantidad siempre si
tú quisieras crecer en un 200% bueno
entonces tendrías que multiplicar por 3
es decir el triple de nuestra cantidad y
quiero ser muy claro en esto si
tuviéramos multiplicando por uno bueno
pues realmente estaríamos sumando un 0%
si estuviéramos multiplicando por 2
bueno realmente estaríamos sumando un
100% 100% más de lo que teníamos
anteriormente
y si quisiéramos multiplicarlo por 3
entonces al triplicar esta cantidad
estaríamos sumando un 200% espero que
sea mucho más claro esto